[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
sex for a long time oh goodness i'm
rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting we're
getting into
part one of four
of our
sex sub series this episode and then the
next three episodes
are going to be all based in sex we'll
guide you through based
that's what the kids say based in space
that means something that's bad we'll
walk you through what what each of these
episodes is going to be in a second but
how did you how did you prep for this i
thought a lot about sex and by that i
mean did you have sex last night
um
did i have sex last night you heard me i
did not have sex last night because my
wife stayed up late and i was like i got
to go to bed because i'm going to be
talking all about sex in the morning and
i want to be fresh well i i had this
idea in my mind i was like you know the
best prep
is going to be like give a little nookie
and get a little nooky last night and
prep for this but
we're trying to re-watch through lord of
the rings is a family
and then after that christian nothing
will buzz kill a buzz like the lord of
the rings we had a show that christy and
i wanted to watch so we we stopped lord
of the rings and then chris and i
watched something and then by the time
that was over i was like man i'm getting
up i gotta i gotta ride my mountain bike
in the morning and that's not euphemism
it's getting you literally are gonna
ride them it's getting late i mean by
that i mean it's 9 30 p.m
so yeah i didn't get to i didn't do all
of my homework for for this episode but
i will say when i when i do sort the
mail it's something to talk about which
i guess for
something
you know
in in a subsequent episode it well in
the
third episode we're going to talk about
our sex lives currently oh yeah and i
think i'm ready
i'm ready to do that come on
uh oh gosh so we're going to talk about
our sex lives
in episode three as well as
the dynamics of
parenting
in a in a sex-drenched world oh no
talking to our talking to your kids
about sex and in the fourth episode the
fourth episode we are going to be taking
the questions that have just built up
like years of sexual tension
um and just releasing our answers
uh in the fourth episode they're not our
questions
your question so use hashtag your
biscuits even starting now as you're
listening to this
start
letting us know tweeting at us
what questions you want us to tackle
they can be
um personal
in nature or they can be
philosophical in nature well i don't
know i think most of the questions that
no no no no bard and you can use what's
the word no no holds bar no holds barred
you can use the episodes over the next
three episodes that we're going to
explore different themes and different
things uh to kind of lead what other you
might have clarifying questions i'm sure
you're going to have a lot of clarifying
questions but if you want to go ahead
and ask us some stuff go for it episode
2 which is the next episode
we're going to be talking about
purity culture growing up and
experiencing that firsthand within the
southern white evangelical church but
today we're going to talk about
uh
how we first learned about sex and what
we first thought about sex as
kids growing up
uh but before we get into that i do have
a theme song that i've been working on
you have i haven't told you about this
and i haven't really prepared it it
looks like you're about to sing it it
goes a little something like this
if you want to hear two straight white
sis dudes who
only have had sex with one woman each
and waited until they got married to
have sex with those women that they only
had sex with each if they've only had
sex with one woman each and they both
been married for about 20 years if that
sounds cool those guys talking about sex
for a month
i'm trying to find my key
then strapping strap on stop and get
ready for sex timber
i mean i i didn't really have it
prepared but it could have changed you
could have sung multiple notes you but
you did no no it seemed like it was like
one note yeah it's kind of got that 90s
thing that the
i hate it anyway uh that's the theme
song i won't sing it again i don't think
people really understood
the substance of what you were trying to
say which i think is important because
the song was so bad it was kind of a
disclaimer uh yes
we're a couple of
middle-aged
uh
straight cis white dudes
who both waited until we got married to
have sexual intercourse with our wives
who we are still married to
and have only ever had sex with
uh for
21 and 20 years respectively this could
be the most boring
sex series you've ever listened to but i
don't actually don't think so i think we
got some i mean
i think we got something for you well
and we say that because we reckon this
is not a prescriptive sex advice series
right we're going to be answering
questions i guess in the fourth episode
but it's really this is just us telling
you our story this is one point on the
wide spectrum of perspectives uh and
it's not prescriptive it's just personal
and anecdotal and we do what you will we
reserve the right to be wrong about
things and to change our mind a week
after the podcast comes out yeah or
longer
because we're
we're we're still in process yeah second
piece of this disclaimer it's going to
get graphic it probably already has
gotten a little bit more graphic than
you're used to it's going to get
significantly more graphic so if the
idea
of your favorite internet dads
or talking about brothers yeah whatever
you want to call or internet sons
talking of
explicitly
and graphically about their own sexual
thoughts and exploits and biographically
we we're going to have graphics that's
what we mean by that we're going to have
illustration we're going to have
animated illustrations some people will
not realize that he is currently being
uh facetious or sarcastic
but he is just short of that it it might
make you uncomfortable with your choice
we're going to paint very graphic mental
pictures for you and
we're not going to
i'm just saying we're not really going
to hold back and it's going to make you
feel uncomfortable if that kind of thing
makes you feel uncomfortable and so i'm
just letting you know if you don't like
the idea of us talking like that or
hearing us talk like that or you got
somebody in your family that might
listen with you normally now's the time
to stop just skip september and do
something in the earbuds because i'm
about to say female orgasms
yeah if you've if if you don't take
anything else away from this series
spoiler alert
female orgasms right we're going to get
into that
let's go way back before we ever heard
about any of that what's the first thing
you remember thinking about sex
ah
i don't have a recollection of of first
i i can't answer that
you've blanked it you've blocked it out
like i have some things that i think
will come up and then maybe it'll i can
backtrack into
it but
um
it was just something that
i was gonna say was thrust upon me but i
don't want to use that verb let me put
the question back on you
because maybe do you have an answer i
think
i know enough about you to believe that
you have probably a handful of answers
now that you said both thrust and
handful i have to give a third part to
the disclaimer and that is
we are still at heart 12 year old boys
okay and we're gonna keep
seeing the innuendo in things that we
say unintentionally and laughing like 12
year old boys they've watched good
mythical okay they said if that's not
that's not a surprise that annoys you
that's going to happen a lot too so
surprised
um
you know
i was attracted to girls as far back as
i can remember
i remember in first grade
uh we had the split class first and
second grade so first grade when i met
you
uh in miss locklear's class
i remember having crushes on various
girls in that class
and i would have dreams about them
and in those dreams i would i didn't
know anything about sex i had
like literal zero idea about the what
the penis i knew the penis was involved
but i didn't understand how it was
involved and i wasn't actually that's
specifically curious about it so in my
dreams i there was just a lot of kissing
or the idea of what kissing might be
just being close to a girl right
uh but i had no idea but when you said a
girl
but these are specific girls that you
were dreaming i am not going to be
mentioning specific
names don't say the names but i'm saying
specific girls yeah yeah it was it was
specific yeah um
and like i would have dreams and i would
like because i was in that day i was
flying in my dreams and i would
realize i was dreaming and then realized
i would could fly to their house and
then i would and their dad would always
answer the door and say she can't come
outside it was awkward and weird but
so never really successfully
you know achieved anything in my dream
but again all i knew that i was going to
do was kiss them so okay so
i thought you might be getting at
nocturnal admissions here but you're not
we're not going in for a smog check yet
uh no interesting
i'll get into because how old how old
were you i'm talking like
six and seven okay yeah all right so i
don't think it was even possible at that
point i don't i i
i wouldn't think so now i know that my
parents had no idea that i was thinking
about any of these things because i
didn't we didn't talk about those things
and i'm going to go i'm going to go
ahead and say
i did not confirm this with my mom and
dad because i didn't want to have this
conversation with them as an adult man
okay but uh and maybe that says
something about me but i do not remember
getting the talk from my parents
now i'm not throwing my parents under
the bus because it was it was the early
80s and i don't i didn't know many
friends at all who received a talk from
their parents it was
that's much more common now with parents
and children
than it was at least where we come from
also as the younger brother they may
have given the talk to my older brother
but i think that you just there's a
trickle-down economics sort of thing
that happens in uh most families just
like we tell the old one and the rest of
them will figure it out
that's kind of what i mean that's
in the third with the third episode but
that's kind of what happened in my
current family that i am the father of
right
um i got you so anyway
didn't have a talk
so and it didn't talk to anyone else
about it so these things were just
happening
in my brain but i had not made any
connections to the physicality of how
any of this works i hadn't even made the
connection between an erection
and
like sexual like what okay then what
happens well why is that thing happening
why is this thing hard right now what
might that lead to no no connections but
so it was a fixation on certain girls
that you had crushes on that was that
was like the fuel for your there was a
lot of for your thoughts sexual energy
directed specifically
at girls and then at specific girls that
you didn't have wet dreams girl
girlfriends at a young age
you know
yeah i know there are some there were
there were some classmates of ours girls
and boys who
were like
they would have a little boyfriend or
girlfriend type thing but you never had
that i never had that i had a crush on
one girl in
kindergarten
and
at nap time i looked over and she was
sucking her thumb
and that
it was i didn't have a sexual response
to that
i was just like oh i only very recently
stopped sucking my thoughts yeah i get
it
but i remember like
really crushing on her and what did what
did that mean but it wasn't much of a
fixation and i don't recall it lasting
that long and it was you weren't like i
want to be that thumb so bad it was it
felt it felt weird and definitely
something that i would never tell
anybody about or acknowledge publicly
of course never to her never you know
it was i mean years later
i was still like
i mean the first girlfriend i got was in
seventh grade well mine was and i was
sixth grade and i didn't want and i
didn't want any i didn't want my family
to know that i had a girlfriend i was
very nervous i was very nervous around
girls and i and i felt like
they could tell
that they were driving me wild you know
what i'm saying like i'm this like
eight-year-old kid in a conversation
with somebody like oh we're working
together on a project and i just know
that she knows that i'm crazy about her
and that makes me
lock up and not know what to say and be
super awkward so i
i don't i just it never i never thought
to myself oh you can like ask this
person to go with you as we used to say
until six until middle school so but
then without having a talk what was the
next thing for you what was the next
stage well there is a moment in which
the puzzle pieces began to assemble
themselves okay
and i'm going to tell you the first part
of that
right after
you tell everybody
these mugs
we have the official good mythical mug
right here look at that amazing design
and then if you i'm gonna hold yours
if there's no if there's no liquid in it
oh it's just it's just a black mug with
with some logos a little condensation
and then when you add some hot liquid
some hot tea or coffee this thing
magically reveals an amazing design it's
fun it's a
it's something to talk about
and something to drink from mythical.com
i'm estimating
that this was about fourth grade
which would put my brother in about
eighth grade
was he seventh grade seventh grade
seventh grade seventh grade yeah
and uh
we were in georgia where we used to
visit my grandmother and everybody all
our family lives in georgia
and my grandmother's mother
great grandmother
that we call mama johnson
okay
had a shed
a shed
in the backyard
and her
it i think it it had a but it was a lot
of stuff stored in there
like i don't think it was from her late
husband because big john he had been
dead a long time
uh but maybe it was from like remember
those shirts that's where i learned
about sex big johnson shirts well you
gotta i mean you gotta really piece that
together a lot of times there's a lot of
innuendo in those so you're going you
say you're just creeping it
you know there's a shed with a bunch of
stuff in it and we're boys and so it's
just like well you're gonna go in there
and you're gonna start looking around
sure pulling things out looking at it
well a blow up sex doll all of a sudden
my brother is like
well look at this
and he has a calendar
a calendar
featuring
women
sports okay
naked women playing sports every month
it was a different lady in a different
sport in no clothes well i mean like the
the the girl who was skiing
she had on ski boots and she was in skis
she had on a beanie she had on a scarf
but that was it wow she may have been
holding
ski poles i hope she was
at least one you know what i'm saying
there was a girl holding a hockey stick
oh yes
now that i think about it they were all
holding sticks
and i never thought about that i mean
the girl on the slopes is i mean she had
to be a
little little cold well it was all like
you know she wasn't really on the slopes
it was it was a sort of a set okay
but of course a hockey player a skier
that was probably basketball i wasn't
focusing on
the sports
i was focusing on the
the boo-boo-boobies
and this was 1980
you know
five
so we're talking bush city right like we
got we got
there's a lot of bush this untamed bush
all 12 months
okay yeah you're right
it's a perennial evergreen
now i think that's the right word for it
the
uh there there's no talking between me
and my brother at this point but we did
go through the entire year i mean we
went through all the seasons all the
months
no conversation
yes
this is your first name he's probably
thinking
my little brother's looking at this with
me
i definitely don't need he was like i'm
not gonna stop but i'm not gonna like
talk about it you know and we'll never
talk about it again and i don't think we
have
but let me just say
to me
it was the most wonderful thing i had
ever seen in my life it was the most
captivating thing that i had ever
encountered and i mean because you can
you can put you know like
meaningful dates on it and you can plan
things into the future
and you know you you won't double book
that gets really awkward right you know
you get you say yes i'm going to do this
to two people and then you're like oh i
should have put it on it wasn't a naked
chick playing sports count it wasn't the
calendar part that was really getting me
um
but the funny thing is is it wasn't like
there wasn't a a weirdness or a
i don't know what to think about this it
was like
i can't believe that i haven't really
thought about what this might look like
like what a woman's body might look like
and it's better than anything i could
have possibly imagined
it was kind of like i discovered like a
secret to the universe
and wow we just kind of closed it
walked out
and i think a couple additional times
during that trip now we weren't staying
at mama johnson's house we were staying
at mamenel's house her daughter
my grandmother but you were looking for
reasons to go back if i recall correctly
there were a couple of quick trips back
out there and be like
good lord you know and just revisiting
that and again this was super super
super soft core just women standing in
sports poses
naked it sounds like a lot of fun i'd
like to google it and maybe find it we
can put it in the video version of this
okay
well we put this on what our only fans
well we'd have to start one
exactly i don't think you can put other
people on your only fans and kind of
defeats the purpose
i remember
going to my dad's one weekend and he we
rented lethal weapon two i think it was
the one where there's a sex scene in
mel gibson's trailer
and
i remember
that
my my dad was like laying on the bed and
i was down on the floor at the foot of
the bed like sitting sitting on the
floor then watching
the television from down there and i was
really glad that i was down there
because i was super embarrassed
and i was like i'd i'm not i'm not
supposed to be seeing this
i i i was probably in like fourth
grade-ish
and
i that remember that was just my
reaction it wasn't like
i mean it was
it was a sex scene your dad was there my
dad yeah i mean this is not i mean my
brother was there but your dad was there
yeah that certainly made it super
awkward
and um and it wasn't just a nude woman
but there was like they were they were
participating in some sort of act right
they were copulating and i just did not
i don't know how much sense i made of it
but i immediately knew that i was i
should not have been watching this and
this is not something i'd be watching
back at my house
you didn't even have time to uh consider
whether or not you were into the the
idea it was more like i don't think i'm
supposed to be watching this
i was here i was petrified but you were
gentrified of the sex
petrified of the situation of
of me watching something that
was wrong for me to watch this was wrong
for me to to see but was there a moment
where you were like oh that must be i
don't recall that i don't i don't i
don't recall that
i think it was like block you weren't
supposed to see that so block it out i
might have looked away
i wasn't
in especially in that instance i wasn't
intrigued and i don't know if that
happened first or if the next thing i
tell you happened first chronologically
i don't know
and if they happened in the other
direction i had a little bit more
information than i recall but
the way that i found this the way that i
got the sex talk
from my mom was
my mom
uh
always worked at the harney county
health department yes she did and there
was this set of brochures at the front
in the waiting area
and
that was a resource for her all types of
things you know when i was in
um
well shoot i guess this was
well i think this was fifth grade when i
did the drug awareness poster contest
and i told mom i wanted to submit an
anti-drug poster and she was like well
here's an anti-drug brochure
you can just take the illustration from
in that and make that into your poster
you can plagiarize that even though she
nor i
use the word plagiarize and apparently
didn't know what it meant right and
that's why you won and that's why i won
and i have it hanging in whole county
you won the whole county i still got a
laminated version of it hanging in there
no one in the county might put together
that this is from the official house
office this is from the official county
anti-drugs brochure which yeah probably
we're gonna take the winner of this and
use it in the brochure and they're like
oh this is the same image from last year
there's a lot of fun things to do
instead of drugs right was was their
tagline and sex yeah
she also came home one day and said
something to the effect of
link i want
you to read this
brochure
and then if you have any questions
you you can talk to me about it
it's any questions you have it's totally
fine you can just ask me anything
to clarify anything
that you read in this amazing brochure
what was the illustration on the outside
of this brochure i don't remember but
it definitely if it was just text and
illustrations it's i'm pretty sure
there was no actual photos this is not
and it was and there was no sex
positions either this was a very
clinical
educational brochure did you read it i'm
estimating i was still in like around
fourth fifth grade
and
i was like okay mom and i took the thing
and i remember i went into my room and i
closed the door
and then i went into my closet
and i closed myself in my closet
wow like pushed
i i had this little cubby area that i
could sit in
inside of my closet and hide
like push my when you're doing bad
things like learning about sex yes
so i went in there and had like a
flashlight or something
and i read this brochure
and i and i don't recall
um
any sort of
positive
reaction any sort of intrigue
associated with it
i don't know that there was an aha
moment this was not something i wasn't
asking any questions i was not
i i was not
motivated to find any of this out
now i think it was probably a good time
for mom to give me the brochure because
sometimes
you just you need to have some point of
reference for things so you can kind of
keep up i applaud
your mom for this i mean
you know yeah i'm not critiquing how she
did it well no but it does say a lot
about me and how i responded to it
i mean
it also says a lot about your sort of
lingering obsession
with brochures
like you ended up being a brochure
collector
well into yeah your teenagers i didn't
go to a lot of uh tourist destinations
but i had brochures for a lot of stuff
and it's you know brochures played a
really integral role
in your life but anyway i do think this
one was very biological it i mean
it it gave
it showed an erection
it showed an erection i thought you said
there weren't pictures diagram it showed
a diagram of an erection but it was like
a cross-section of an entire human being
so you could see the inside of the
erection
but who wants to see inside who wants to
see an erection at all but did you know
like oh that's what happens to me i
don't i don't remember that i don't
remember
it i probably did think that i know i
was in the closet
and i know that i just felt like this
was a clandestine
thing
that
it was i mean
there was a shame element i don't want
anyone to know
that i'm reading this book god forbid
find it this is just strange
and i think that's a i i think that
that's a pretty well i may have been a
little bit more driven and inquisitive
about it
i still wasn't talking to anybody about
it for the same reason i was i was i i
felt
i was going to ask my parents a question
about it because i was
it's weird and there's a lot of shame
attached to it and culture i mean i have
to conclude that at the time my takeaway
was
because it was
it was just it was so educational in a
biological sense like this is
this is these are ovaries this is a
vagina this is an erection this these
are gonads you know
that type of situation so
my takeaway must have been more this is
how you make babies and i don't want to
worry about it i don't really recall
being engaged making a connection
between desire
pleasure
intimacy
i
i ventured to guess that none of that
stuff was really covered maybe more than
just a blurb
in this thing it might have covered stds
but i'm pretty sure that would have lost
me right you know because i i was just
like i'll get back to this later i don't
know what i did with the brochure i have
to think i hid it somewhere in a stack
of stuff in case i needed to refer to it
later but i never i didn't throw it away
it's right better i can't remember the
railroad brochure yeah right i did
i mean i would call it a pamphlet it had
multiple pages it wasn't like a three up
three right it was a three panel
brochure it was a booklet um okay so i
didn't get that and no one gave me any
technical education so i should have
given you mine yeah i wish you had if we
were talking about it but but i think as
you'll see
i think as you'll see the way that my
story unfolds there is a
i'm not necessarily unhappy with the way
that it came together because at least
it makes a good story of how i put these
pieces together there's a happy ending
definitely the second piece
of the puzzle
uh came from a sleepover at a friend's
house around that same time i'm still
estimating same year fourth grade or
whatever you were doing a lot of
sleeping around
yeah as you as you may know i was not i
invited myself over to anyone's house uh
like the first day of school if i met
you i would invite you myself over to
your house because i was really
interested in people's homes and
especially their fridges
but anyway this was a a friend and we
were there were several people who were
going to be staying over at his house
and we were all sleeping in
uh like a rec room situation and he had
an older brother
who was even older than my brother who
was already in high school
and
i mean that's where you get so much
information it's from these older
brothers they're just there's there's
just
you know yeah they got so much wisdom
about sex
yeah
but he had told his younger brother a
number of things which then were relayed
to us and the one detail that i remember
really standing out because it freaked
me the hell out
was he said yeah i'll find his
underwear
and his underwear has dried sperm in it
and i was like what's he doing taking
like core samples well and he didn't you
know and he didn't say dried sperm he
just said sperm and at this point
i thought
for reasons i don't understand i thought
that sperm was a powder
okay because that that's what you
inferred from his story yes there's
something in your pants and it's it's
probably powder
so i was just so that was the first time
that i was like oh something else comes
out of your penis other than pee and
that's got something to do with the sex
stuff it's like bc headache medication
but it comes out in like a poop
like one of those mushrooms that you
find that yeah your kids need
yeah give it a little squeeze it's like
squeezing a thing of baby powder
it's airborne oh no anyone can get
infected oh god
um so i don't know why but i thought
that it was a powder
but i i took that nugget with me
and
again i'm i'm i've seen the women the
naked ladies playing sports i know that
the more that i see of a woman's body
the more i'm into it and now i'm like
there's this second piece of the puzzle
which is i've got this ability to like
puff out some powder from my penis under
certain circumstances that i'm not i'm
not yet aware of how this is going to
happen but apparently it can happen
while sleeping that was the whole point
of his he was like pumping out penis
power but he didn't call it wet dreams
because if he had called it wet dreams i
wouldn't have come up with a powder nope
you wouldn't have you know
what dreams and powder that doesn't mix
younger brother looking at older
brothers underwear is
weird
hey but yeah i mean apparently he was
inquisitive too okay now
i'm this is gonna i'm getting very don't
i'm not gonna go for effort just go
forward
i know i just
um
okay so i distinctly remember i had
these pieces of information
uh in sixth grade
like probably summer before sixth grade
rolls around
and i had not ever
masturbated
okay okay i didn't and by that you mean
i had i did not know what masturbation
was
i knew that i would get these
erections
but it was just like well there's that
thing happening i hope no one sees
you know what i'm saying i've put up but
my back i'm going to carry my backpack
really low as i go to the lunchroom or
whatever you know hang it right on there
like a doorknob yeah um
but i never masturbated
but
again no i it's crazy how i was piecing
this together because it was just based
on this these disparate pieces of
information but i'm lying there in my
bed at night and here it comes you know
we've got full mast situation
and and then i'm like well let's just
let it breathe
[Laughter]
you know i remember thinking all this
stuff like powder and let it breathe yes
well i just remember thinking i mean
this is the first time it happened yeah
so
it's out and it's in the open air and
then i just i just kind of i just i just
grabbed it you know i just put my hand
around it
and the reason i'm telling you in this
graphic situation is because of how this
happened so i didn't understand what a
fantasy was and i didn't understand what
masturbation was but i began to imagine
don't make me feel don't make me feel
stupid for telling you this i'm not i'm
not don't make me feel super telling me
everyone knows am i making you feel
stupid what am i doing i told you what
am i doing when we started this podcast
that in 2021 i'm going to talk about the
first time i ever masturbated would you
have been like let's not let's just stop
this podcast now are you like okay let's
see where this thing goes dude i'm
hanging on every word i want to know if
it was powerful i was hanging onto my
dick
so uh
i'm sitting there and i began to have
this
i didn't even understand what i was
having was a fantasy i began to imagine
that i was lying on a table
in a hospital
with my full erect penis
sticking out like from underneath a
sheet and that nurses who just happened
to be all the girls from our school who
i thought were cute what were coming by
and like investigating it and like
testing it like putting their hands on
it being like yep that's a it's a penis
yep it's okay like look i had this weird
fantasy
and of course the whole time
i'm touching myself in a pleasurable way
and
then about literally like after 10
minutes of this
i'm like boy this feels good
like this feels so good it feels like
something
like it feels like something weird is
happening like i didn't you know i
didn't understand what the beginning of
an orgasm might feel like one thing led
to another so there's
there's there's a line up that's
happening yeah and i mean i'm talking
listen there's a batter on deck and and
you know and so all of a sudden it's
just like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what has happened and then poof some
powder came out
wow
no hold your breath uh
there was the moment of release
and it was not powder
so i immediately thought i had broken my
dick
oh no
and i was like
is it what it's good that i'm in a
hospital i was
i was like is it blood oh god like i i
honestly i was like it's not pee i know
that because it feels like soap
and i was like i did it did i get soap
in there what i did i was freaking
you talking about soft soap the first
type of liquid soap we had was a brand
called soft soap very soft and that was
probably what you were thinking and i
was like did i did i get some soft soap
in there when i took a bath i
i was really concerned and then i was
like who am i gonna talk to about this
and as i sat there in my bed piecing
together the calendar
the
conversation about sperm which then i
realized oh do you only assume that it
was powder
this is sperm yeah and
the funny thing is is i you know i'm
sitting there i'm a real thing i'm like
i'm like 12 years old 11 12 i don't know
and
i
it was like a cave boy i don't want to
i'm not trying to make the the adults in
my life especially my parents like feel
i mean that i was just piecing this
together but it was like it was like a
it was like lord of the flies it was
just like
cave boy sitting there ooh there were
flies figuring out
what sex was yeah but the way that it
was kind of locking into place it was
the complete opposite of a brochure you
know i'm saying like you had the
brochure that had the technical
information i'm sitting there thinking
i've broken my penis and then realizing
that oh sperm is not powder
that's what just happened i can tell you
that the brochure did not say anything
about
masturbation i think i would have
remembered that well there was no how-to
let me just say once i broke the seal
you thought i became a connoisseur
so you were a soft soap after that so
you on the daily so a long time so you
it was so easy but it
it wasn't the type of thing that would
ever come up in conversation with your
brother
hell no and it wasn't the type of thing
that as an older brother he would joke
about you jerking off
because that would validate it no no no
no he didn't and that is very common
that's very common now i hear those
jokes in my own home right um but no um
there was there was no external
validation and you you certainly you
never talked to me about it maybe in
like movies maybe like in pop culture
you know i was like oh yeah that's what
they're talking about now i know what
whacking off or jerking off is no that's
the thing that i do all the time now
it's my new thing it's the best thing
that i've ever done
yeah you know okay
i uh
i i can't recall
the first time i masturbated
really i don't i really can't i i think
that well first of all the older brother
of it all of course i didn't have that i
was an only child
and then
i also didn't
like at this point i had a dad in the
house but he was a nice guy but we
weren't that close and there was never
and he wasn't type of guy to like make
any off-handed i couldn't off-handed
jokes or anything like that so it wasn't
like i learned anything from him he had
a daughter who was
much older than me it was you know we
weren't having any conversations there
was nothing to be learned there and
again i had
i was not motivated i was not interested
i was not asking questions and i think
when i was presented with information
even
a brochure or a movie i wasn't supposed
to be seen or i remember one time
there was like these older kids at my
who stayed at the same babysitter as me
after school and during the summer and
he he was like
real sex obsessed
and he i remember he used the word
clitoris
or clitoris as you do i don't know how
he said it i was like what is this guy
talking about a clitoris like i mean i
was i mean i was
i was like what
i i did okay it's like now i've heard a
word that is something that this
raunchy dude is saying that now goes in
my
pretend you didn't hear that
column it was probably in the brochure
but i think that that's that must have
been how i reacted to these things for
me to not have these
active vivid memories like you do it was
a suppression thing
it was
i'm not suppo i'm this is not i'm not
supposed to know about this stuff
i don't
care to know about this stuff so i'm
gonna act like i don't know about it and
then after a while
when you're not re-accessing those
memories
and and fixating on it then it kind of
fades into the background that's at
least my explanation
in hindsight because it feels like i
can't i mean if that was your attitude
towards sex
then you would have waited so it would
have been
later like
middle school high school whatever
and if there was so much trepidation
around it it just feels like the moment
that you decided to do it would be would
stand out
um
i i think it was there was do you
remember that
there was a shame associated with it i
remember one time in particular
um we were being picked up to go
somewhere
like you you had gotten a ride with
somebody i actually think it was these
these older girls that were in our youth
group and they were old enough to drive
and then they came by and and picked me
up to go somewhere to go to some church
thing
and then i remembered that i'd left
something at home
and i can't and i was like oh you got to
take me back home to get so and so can't
remember what it was so we turn around
at the end of the street and we go back
and i go in the house to get the thing
and i look on the couch
and i had left the victorious secret
magazine out on the couch
okay and i had been looking at the
victoria's secret magazine and i have to
believe that i was
jerking off
you have to i have to i have to believe
it i mean at the they would there would
be all these it would be the nice
lingerie and then you'd get to the back
and it would get lazier
the back of the victoria secret if you
if you made it that far you got into
really good stuff right a lot more lace
sometimes you you could feel like you
could almost see a nipple but you really
couldn't but you almost could i mean and
then but like they would have those like
stockings that would then come up to
like the middle of the thigh and then
there would be like a little connector
like a
strap from the stocking to the panties
i'm aware i'm aware of this and i
remember i i did fixate on that like
that was my jam well the thing is is i
got to a place where i didn't need that
it could just be like a woman in the
sears catalog holding a vacuum oh and
just there's enough cleavage and i'll be
like i mean literally there was when
they talk about like sex crazed
sort of when you get like when you're
going through puberty and the hormones
or you're just saturated in hormones
it got to it was it got to a place
thankfully it didn't that stage of my
life didn't last where it
the
the simplest
thing
could could could just be like oh well
yeah you just now you need to go
masturbate the thing for me that i
remember about that is first of all
it could have been eighth grade
honestly
maybe seventh grade
don't it wouldn't have been less than
that like my mom was at home we were
like we were in the
the new house course that had been a
while i'm trying i i i'm gonna say it's
seventh grade but it could have been
eighth grade and i mean i i was
definitely
suppressing going to any of these places
in my mind and you know i was a i was a
late bloomer i think you would call it
that you know
developmentally i was a i was i was
behind i believed in santa claus
many years
later than you thought was appropriate
and and and you remedied it right
thank you for for letting me know and
thank you for not telling me about the
powder because that would have really
freaked me out and thinking about not
telling me about any of your um
discoveries or maybe i don't know maybe
i wish you would have told me but i do
remember with the
victoria's secret thing in that moment i
was like oh [ __ ]
if i wouldn't have come back in here to
get my so-and-so i would have then that
magazine would have been sprawled out
and my mom would know i was looking at
it and i put it back where it was
supposed to be and put it away
i had all of these weird shame things as
as around this time like when i started
growing my
realizing that like i had a unibrow
and you told me that i couldn't shave it
i needed to pluck it i didn't have
tweezers but i knew my mom had tweezers
because i had like gotten the toenail
clippers from her
drawer in her bathroom
and i saw that there were tweezers in
there so what i would do is i would just
go borrow my mom's tweezers but i
wouldn't do the thing that seems totally
normal which is
tell my mom hey mom
i want to plug these eyebrows
can i'm going to use your tweezers
i would when my mom was in another room
like in the kitchen or something i would
walk from my bedroom across the living
room remember how it was all the way
into her bedroom and her bathroom and i
would take her tweezers and i would
sneak back out into my my bathroom and
pluck my eyebrows because i was ashamed
that i was doing that
i just
like so if i was ashamed of plucking my
eyebrows in front of my own mom which is
kind of sad
how much more when it came to this
this unknown world of
sexuality and you know going through
puberty and and so much unknown and yeah
my mom my mom did a good job of saying
hey
we
like she used proper
terms growing up like penis we didn't
talk about vaginas ding-dong um did you
say ding-dong in the brochure she
fostered open communication when it came
to biology and things like that and she
left an open door for questions
and so i'm not putting any of this on my
mom but something about the way that i
was and what i don't know
everything i'd gone through there was
like i had a predisposition towards
shame i think
in in other areas so you you layer that
on this and i'm like the last thing i
want anybody to know is that i
masturbate
and i'm
so i just kind of have this innate
belief that no one can ever know
no one can ever know well it's
interesting because
i am a deeply shameful person
like as an enneagram three shame is your
main vice
um
and
as we will get into an exquisite detail
in the next episode
shame is sort of the linchpin of the
purity of purity culture itself
so i was dealing with intense amounts of
shame as
i was beginning to p i was piecing
together
the sexual sort of facts
in my experience and then coupling that
with the christian worldview that i was
saturated in and then would really
embrace as i got older but at this point
did you experience shame you were
keeping it secret you weren't talking to
anybody about it i i think for well i'm
not again i don't
i'm not i'm not diagnosing me or
diagnosing you i'm just saying that it's
interesting because i don't feel like
the main difference was no okay yeah i
plucked my eyebrows and i had a
conversation with my mom about that so i
wasn't ashamed about that but when it
came to the sex the idea that anyone
would know that this stuff was happening
that i was thinking these things i had
no way to know that it was a completely
normal thing i i for all intents and
purposes i thought that i was strange
and weird
and
all these desires were bad and wrong but
they were so intense
that it didn't matter you know what i'm
saying like i mean as we'll talk about
next episode the the idea of
both at the same time holding the idea
that masturbation is sinful and wrong
and then holding your penis and
masturbating a lot at the same time for
many many years creates quite a christ
create that attaches so much shame to
sex so that was happening at the same
time so i guess i'm just throwing that
i'm adding that piece of information
because it feels like you're tying
your shame
to
the way that you
uh
like saw it but like i had a lot of
shame around it too but at the same time
it was just so intense
that i couldn't
i couldn't stop it do you know what i'm
saying yeah and i
i did i didn't have that much of a drive
and it did happen
much later for me but i did like get
hair on my legs earlier right and that
kind of thing so what what so what is
the next what's the next step in your
process um
and i'll i'll tell you where
you know if i'm if i'm later well i'll
jump in when it
when i can relate to it again so this
was this was sixth grade if and again
i'm i'm a year or so off
probably in these but so yeah this whole
the pieces of the puzzle coming together
is like fourth fifth sixth grade like
getting ready for middle school
sixth grade uh at a party
that
i could have sworn you were at
birthday party overnight sleepover at
somebody's house
uh it was the one where we
put someone's hand in the warm water
trying to make them pee on themselves
um
and we and and again just so you know
what's this chainsaw mask that's
exciting okay yeah just so you don't
think we're bullies we all talked about
it ahead of time whoever falls asleep
first is gonna this is going to happen
to them so it was agreed upon
it didn't work by the way it doesn't
work it's like an urban legend now
there was a moment where we went outside
in the birthday boy
was like i've got something i want to
show you guys
and he broke out a penthouse magazine i
don't remember this
i i do not remember this oh i remember
it
if i was there maybe i was like i'm
gonna i'm gonna go inside and not be a
part of this or it may have been two
different times but go ahead and
we all gathered around five six
boys
with a flashlight
and we turned the pages
and
uh for those of you who are not porn
initiated uh
the calendar showed
bush
penthouse showed what the bush was
hiding yeah you can get
get it get in the bush and uh
exquisite detail
and which i think is the second time
i've used it from exquisite detail in a
short period of time uh but
i remember another kid there
made this specific comment no one
understood the placement of the vagina
to be graphic we didn't we didn't under
we kind of thought that it was like oh
it's just where the penis is but then
we're like oh no it's not it's like it's
lower and i remember one kid saying
it extends
it extends
so like
it extends because it was like you know
you could see like it's you could see
the whole anatomy the relationship of
the
different orifices
yeah and there was this like
conversation about it but this like
stand by me level of like wonderment
being exchanged by these middle school
boys so amazing that you don't remember
this i did that you like i was not there
you must have just i was not there but i
would not have said it extends i might
would have said it opens it blossoms no
meaning it extends further than anybody
understood
you know what i'm saying it's taller
than i thought well it goes lower than
anyone thought okay okay
and i just remember like it was like the
final piece of the puzzle had fallen in
place
and i remember thinking to myself i feel
like i have found my purpose in life
and this is what my hand is simulating
and it is a vagina and i i mean i'm just
i'm not trying to i'm not trying to be
funny here like it was so
crazy
like
exactly more than i could ever imagine
it was like i was a space traveler going
throughout the galaxy looking for my
home planet and finding it and like this
is the place i came from and this is the
place i must return
you know it was oh it was
so powerful and it sticks out in my
memory
and again
i also was just thinking this is gonna
be trouble
like because this is the only thing i'm
gonna be able to think about the fact
that this exists and you can just get a
magazine and look at it
again i know it might feel and i i
this may seem crazy to some some people
who don't who don't have that much
sexual attraction but
like it was
overwhelming to me i i totally get it at
this at that point in my life i
certainly did not but i i mean
i i totally understand now
just for the record between then and now
there was a point closer to then than
now that i did figure all this out and i
was uh
a lot more motivated than i was when you
started that's the reason i say that
because i don't again i've never talked
about any of this publicly and i've only
talked about it with a few people
privately you don't want to seem like a
creep uh like just being just seeing a
vagina and thinking that it's by far the
best thing
that the universe has ever created like
by far the best thing it's ever created
and i still believe that to this day the
vagina is the pinnacle of creation
okay you say it again the vagina is the
pinnacle of creation
i still believe that i still feel that i
am a cho does that make me i just say i
feel i just say in my humble opinion i
still have oh yeah in my humble opinion
i still have
there's shame associated with that like
am i a creep for thinking that or is it
the shame that we're going to explore in
the next episode where it comes from my
world view that like was paired with
this no
there should there's we we do know that
there should not be
and yeah so there's nothing to apologize
for okay good here but it i mean i it
it's extraordinary how different we were
at this time that if i was there it i
probably
physically got out because i just didn't
feel like i could allow
that it wasn't allowed that was off
limits that was
x-rated
i'm almost willing to say
that this and again i'm not trying to be
facetious
but for me as an agnostic
my
best evidence for the existence of god
is the vagina
okay and now you're if you keep going
you are gonna get it's like okay dude we
get it it's cool that's cool no but let
me just give my theory real quick
because okay
it's sort of shaped like it's kind of
shaped like a a bean right like it's
it's oblong there's a there's a bean
that's part of it again you know as you
said the clitoris earlier and then this
whole shape is reminiscent of the shape
of the galaxy which is probably the
shape of the universe
you know what i'm saying it's like i
just think it's all it's like it's like
a uh
this shape within a shape within a shape
within a shape it's just like i i think
that i'm not joking when i say that
like i'm you know i'm like okay this
feels like an intentional creation yeah
if that's your thing
great i won't say anything else about it
right it's just you know it's
to me it's not about oh does that does
that make you look like a creep it's
like does something like this
do people map that on their own
experience and then judge themselves and
i get concerned about that but i'm
actually not going to oh yeah i'm not
saying i'm not saying you should feel
this way i'm just saying i'm trying to
just
articulate my own experience and you may
not have thought about it to that degree
at the time but you did think about it
almost to that degree and then
and you experienced this reaction and
then there might have been a secondary
or tertiary reaction that was
i'm not going to tell anybody about this
or talk about it i mean the guys on the
trampoline you were you were there was a
lot of conjecture but then in all in our
friend group there was never
there was there weren't there wasn't
joking about uh masturbation or i think
it just started body parts until high
school
in my recollection yeah it got very
prevalent in high school but there was
something to socially connecting with
other boys about it and again
uh we talked about our we were still
best friends at this time
we've always been best friends and the
only the other person i was really close
with was ben
and we didn't like ben and i didn't talk
about it and you and i didn't talk about
it and it was kind of like something
reserved for a few friendships
that like due to you could like you set
down a porn magazine in front of and you
just all start kind of just doing it on
and there was some sort of connection at
that point
um
which began to sort of break down some
of the bonds for me it was oh these guys
are just as fascinated by this as i am
and that makes me feel normal
that was that was an important step for
me i remember seeing porn whenever we
would go in the woods we would find porn
and we would we would look at it some in
the woods
and then yeah in between
the school and home
is
there was there was a stretch of woods
where we found and then re-hid the porn
because you don't want the porn at your
house you want the porn in the woods so
you and then so
i remember thinking and again we were
the church stuff does start to come in
even in middle school it's like all
right we definitely knew you should not
be looking at porn
this was wrong that's why you hide it in
the woods but you hide it under like a
piece of metal so when it rains it can
stay dry even though it still gets
really damp and every time you come back
to it it's a little more decrepit and
then you finally get so guilty that you
go out there one day and you're like i'm
going to burn it and then you don't burn
it and then you come and then you just
look at it and then you go out there the
next time and you're like i'm really
gonna burn it and you look at it and
then the third time you're like okay
i'm just gonna burn it i'm not gonna
look at it well it begins to lose its
effect you're like oh yeah i've seen the
girl with the hockey stick yeah yeah and
then i burned it yeah and then you can
burn it but i remember i we both knew it
was there and i think i remember having
a conversation telling you that i burned
it and i didn't care because i had found
porn stashes not not in my own home okay
but at other people's houses like other
kids i was friends with had found their
dad's porn stashes
yeah i remember one of those and of
course porn stash sounds like a porn
mustache but i'm talking like a stash of
porn a stack of playboys in in the
walk-in closet and it's like behind most
kids knew where their dads kept the porn
stash
and
they would you know gladly share it
because it made it it was it made your
house cooler
so
nicki minaj is pre-internet we know
obviously nobody had internet so this
brings me to the grok because i think
there's still
when do you okay so
are you ready to tell that story sure
yeah i'm trying to remember when this
was this is you know
summer of couldn't drive yet i know that
it was i mean i'm guessing this is
summer after seventh grade that sounds
about right and we would just ride our
bikes around
bowie's creek
all hot summer long
because this was also before we got
summer jobs we weren't old enough
to get summer jobs
which i think happened after my eighth
grade year started working for my dad or
maybe it was ninth grade so anyway we're
in the right territory
and at the edge of campus there was a
now torn down and totally rebuilt with
something fancy there was this really
old
gas station building that didn't have a
gas pump in front anymore it was just a
convenience store no longer serving gas
and it was called the grok short for
grocery and we would go in there and
play the gilligan's island pinball
machine
and
baseball cards were a huge craze
and that's where you would go to
buy and sell baseball cards at the grock
and there was some [ __ ] some
what i felt was like some shady dude who
worked there definitely shady and then
all summer long all these baseball cards
would be coming in and going out because
there would be
camps all summer all types of sports
camps but no naked sports camps
in retrospect and
the guy kind of
knew that we weren't campers because we
were there week after week after week
playing the gilligan zion thing and he
was like hey if you guys want to sort my
baseball cards for me i'll give you a
dollar an hour like hell okay
that's good money and i was like
i wonder
is this okay can i do this and we're
like yeah let's do this so he said just
go to the back there's a bunch of
baseball cards that need to be sorted
and you can do it on this
pool table use the pool table as your
desk there's all these baseball cards up
there we're looking in the pool table
and
where all the
billiard balls would gather
like underneath the
the pool table
like those cubbies there
whether you would hide all the the pool
table
accoutrement yeah there was pouring in
there lots of pork i mean like if you if
you ran
and bumped into the pool table porn
would just fall out it was i mean it was
coming out of every orifice of this pool
table if i remember correctly yeah it
wasn't like one magazine or three
it was like every orifice was rolled up
shoved in stacked up smushed just in
there yeah it was strange and that was
when we began to piece together that we
were gonna get paid one dollar an hour
to just look at porn yeah and which is a
good deal
which is a really you usually have to
pay for it yeah and we so we had we had
to we had to work out some strategy you
got to do some baseball card stuff you
got him you got to demonstrate some sort
of progress to actually get paid but we
do need to look at all of this porn but
we're working for a really low this is a
doom too much basis i mean this is a
treasure trove
of porn do you remember okay so i have i
remember this i remember what we did the
system well
okay we'll talk about the system and
then i i've got a specific thing i
remember the solution was i'm going to
sort baseball cards while you take
your pick of the porn magazines you take
one and you'll go into the bathroom
right over there right that was the
nastiest bathroom and we only made it i
had ever been into yeah it was so gross
this one guy
who worked was the a slob yeah i mean
shoving porn into every
place been sent in a couple of middle
schoolers the bathroom had not been
washed for
decades it was
scary
but we would take shifts so that if at
any point he came back there he can't he
can't know
that we're looking at his porn in my
mind right but he of course because that
would be embarrassing and we probably
get fired and it seemed wrong i didn't i
didn't want this slob of a person
to judge me what
so
we always had an alibi if he came back
there i'm sorting the cards oh he's in
the bathroom
and vice versa so we would take shifts
you'd go in i would go in you would go
in i would go in i could only go in a
few times before i couldn't go in
anymore you know what i mean i never
once masturbated in that bathroom what
never once i thought that was the whole
point
we didn't
we
we talked about this system but we never
talked about jerking off and i feel like
we had to talk about it i thought it was
understood and i'm telling you right now
this is a
this is kind of like a a key date in my
memory because if we're saying this is
summer after seventh grade maybe i
haven't done it yet i hadn't done it yet
you hadn't done it yet if i had done it
i would have done it
i mean that kind of bathroom those kind
of magazines if i knew that you were
prime location i didn't i didn't think
you were doing it well i was because i
didn't know but i was quiet i didn't
know it was a thing to be done
and if i hadn't known you were in there
doing it i certainly wouldn't have kept
going in there right that's gross man no
let me
to be clear i was respecting the system
and i did not i touched
the magazine with one hand in the
my own self with another hand i mean i
didn't there's no cross-contamination
you have to worry about that with me i'm
a professional i'm getting paid a dollar
an hour to masturbate okay i'm one of
the only people that's ever just gotten
paid to masturbate i was so frustrated
and scared of getting caught but i
learned a lot and i were and it this
this porn was not this was a label this
was um this is this was like there are
some porn and again we only had images
we did not have uh video at this point
yeah but there was it was a magazine at
the time
where
the people who made the porn
had come to understand something some
people are only interested in seeing
[Music]
the stuff they want to see
do we have to put them in sports
equipment do we have to make it look
like she's skiing naked do we have to
write an article do we yeah can this and
again
i have
i've seen a lot of porn in my life
but there are certain images
that stick out and one of them is it was
the first time i ever saw the two-page
spread i remember that one and let me
tell you when i say two-page spread i
mean spread definitely and
i just that image sticks out in my mind
and i'm just like i mean it could it
could have been in a biology class the
universe is happening right here in
front of me
um so that's what i remember about that
and i it's funny we've never talked
about the fact that i just assumed you
were going into the bathroom to
whack off as well i didn't even know
i'm sorry man i feel like i should have
told you
but that would have been weird i mean it
was weird anyway because it's like here
i am just waiting for you to i was
interested
and i was
you know and i do remember
the next phase was
let's
i'm gonna steal one of these i'm gonna
put it down my pants and we're gonna
walk out of here with it yeah good idea
and and i that may have been where the
one in the woods came from actually
right get the glossiest one because that
one will resist the rain the longest do
you remember stealing it uh yeah now
that you said it you do it's interesting
because i'm the one who stole it i it
went in my pants and i walked out and
that's that's the only time i don't shop
i don't think i would have stolen it was
that shoplifting i i mean it wasn't for
sale here's the difference between me
and you it was stealing but it wasn't
shoplifting i was afraid of my dad
right and so i felt like yeah i could go
into this bathroom and whack off for
days especially at this rate
but if my dad knows that i stole
something yeah i'm gonna be i i got in
so much trouble when i did things wrong
so i was very good about not like
breaking i would never tempt fate in
that way so by that age i was certainly
motivated to have unfettered access to
pornography yeah uh because here i was
hiding it in the woods right i i
remember walking out with that thing
down my pants and just being with a limp
just a little bit just clean it close
the stiff leg ah you could pay me
tomorrow slob
i'll be back and maybe i was thinking
every day i'll walk out with one down my
pants he'll never notice there's
ourselves 85 of them right
um
well right around that same time
and we can kind of use this as a way to
sort of uh
set the stage for what we're going to
talk about in the next episode
so you got all this stuff that's
happening privately between you and this
woman in a magazine in your own hand
and that's the experience for so many
people but then you start to realize
that oh no like
i could have a girlfriend and i and at
this point i had had
you know i had been in relationships
that were not physical not because of my
choice but because they didn't last long
enough right
but around that same time i i got into a
relationship that was a little bit
longer term
and
more serious and it was with someone who
had kissed other people before right
and so yeah that was when i began to
think oh my goodness it's just like
these unreal sort of these women in
these magazines are not real but this
girl that i'm in a relationship with
is real and but you're you're making
this weird connection now
as a young christian boy who is in the
youth group
the one thing that i know definitively
is that i'm not supposed to have sex and
i and i took that and as you did as well
very seriously as she will come to find
out over the next few episodes
so seriously that
the possibility of having sex with a
girl wasn't even on the radar it didn't
feel like something i remember yeah
specific conversations uh in our friend
group about what the
the kids and dunn were doing
and do you remember that one story there
was one story that one of our friends
told us
about how
the the middle schoolers in dunn
which was the big city would go to the
dunn twin plaza which was the movie
theater
and they would
do the heavy petting hands down the
pants
and he told the story that one girl had
taken
a
i can't believe that this is a story but
had taken a barbie doll's hair
and cut the hair off what yes cut the
hair off the barbie doll and glued it
down there to make it seem like she had
hair
like i remember that i don't remember i
was like this is so my what like what is
what is happening and done like done the
place of debauchery right i mean the
barbie got some long hair that's weird
that's a that's a damn curtain there's
no way that was true it was just one of
those middle school things that people
make up the dumbest [ __ ] it's just like
and i believed it like done they're
doing crazy [ __ ] and done
but i be like i was getting into like
third fourth fifth month of a
relationship
and we were doing lots of lots of
kissing
we're talking you're talking about
eighth grade eighth grade lots of
kissing i had a girlfriend too and we
would we would go to
i mean the guy's house that with the
trampoline
he would have he had a party these these
were makeout parties at this point right
so if you had a girlfriend
um
then you
all those people would go to a room and
start making out with each other right
my interaction with that was
oh i have a girlfriend i'm going to this
party oh [ __ ]
now i gotta i've gotta meet expectations
i've gotta fit in i've gotta
like it it wasn't about an internal
motivation and seizing an opportunity it
was about
meeting expectations in in and fitting
in
despite being very
anxious about it but still
intrigued and
there's i started to be motivated
but i would observe you know it's like
okay this is the room that i'm supposed
to be in because we're a couple and
everyone all the other couples are funny
that's what the the sort of the
framework
of the setting was what was driving your
actions yeah
where i
it was like okay
they're already in here and they're
already making out so i just got to find
another place that we're gonna sit or
like lay down on this couch and make out
with each other and hope to god that the
parents who live here don't come in here
observe something and then report it to
some authority yeah and i felt like i
just had this engine that was just full
like
5 000 rpms all the time
but i was a respectable good kid and so
it wasn't and again i had this
standard that was like well i'm not
going to do and at the time i was like
i'm not going to do anything
uh besides kiss her right because i can
have a lot of fun kissing and i just but
i but the real the only thing that i had
definitively thought in my i was like i
know we're not gonna have sex so i don't
even have to even think about not having
sex because i'm definitely not going to
do that yeah but for some reason
the church lock-in rolls around i mean
talk about a setting not our church it
was the other baptist church in town yes
that felt a little bit
more liberal
and maybe that's why i got a wild hair
literally that night
you know it's so weird the way lock-ins
work and i don't know if this is still
the case but like you put a bunch of
kids in like the fellowship hall in
sleeping bags just next to each other
everybody's supposed to stay awake all
night and do stuff it's keeping kids off
the street and hopefully introducing
them to jesus but then there's this
other room it's like well if you are
sleepy you can lay down on the floor in
this room
and if you want to lay next to your
girlfriend well i guess
we didn't address this so
it's kind of your discretion
remember they were older they were older
there was an older couple in there they
weren't watching too closely but you
don't i mean you can watch closely they
were they were in high school and they
were laying down next to each other and
i was like
why are they in the same sleeping bag
what what's happening awkward i gotta
get out of here well i just wanna i
wanna make a couple of things clear that
consent
was part of the equation for this okay
so this was not
this this was there was consent we were
in a uh
our relationship had been physical up
until this point we had done a number of
things but for some reason and you had
some discussions about it yeah we talked
about it we actually talked about it
very openly
i i mean in some ways i think it's a
very healthy relationship when it came
to that stuff because we talked about
things every step of the way
but
for some reason we took this opportunity
at the church lock-in again the other
churches lock in gosh
in front of all these other people i
mean you were right next to me
and this was my first experience with
heavy petting
underneath the sleeping bag
both ways
me to her hurt or me okay we're sitting
there at the church locking like the the
youth pastor from the other from that
church were like come in and like make
an announcement and be like maybe as the
youth pastor is talking to me maybe i
shouldn't be in the act of heavy petting
i'll pull my hand out like i don't like
the term heavy petting but i do like the
fact that you're using it instead of
being more i just i'm just i'm not i
don't want you to be more graphic but i
do i don't unders i don't like heavy
petting but is there another name for it
no i'm gonna stick with heavy petting
don't make don't don't derail this um
but because you weren't making out
i mean no no you couldn't make out
because that's not allowed because that
would be unkosher for people to sit
there watching you make out so you just
stick your hands down
it wasn't a temple yeah we didn't even
know what kosher was jewish right
uh but jesus was a jew so i think you
can still use the term kosher okay
but i think that what this illustrates
because i be
i began to please when you look at it
well
other just parts of the church you were
like
is it were you whistling
don't look at my hand
um
like you weren't making eye contact with
her well no cause i think if we were
looking at each other and doing that at
the same time i think it would have been
a little too obvious
it's so awkward it's so it's so not the
right way to do it oh of course it isn't
but again it's not the right place again
and
and again this was going this was going
both ways
uh it wasn't like i was this crazy sex
crazed kid and she was just like i don't
know what to do like right this was you
were we were kind of crazy about each
other in this way yeah and
um
the interesting thing is that
there was this intense
physical
connection
and sort of exploration that was
beginning but it was also the same time
when i was beginning to understand
or become as we would say convicted
about
what i was doing i knew that it was
wrong right i knew that i was breaking
some
the
moral code because and i think this is
one of the reasons that we probably i
probably didn't get a talk
because i think my parents philosophy
was well if he's in if he's involved in
the church and he's involved in sunday
school and the youth group we know that
they're going to be talking about these
things and the fact is they were right
because we were having we were being
told very specifically what we should
not be doing by our youth director at
the time
and
so i beg
i began to understand that what i was
doing was wrong and began to associate a
very high level of guilt and shame with
those actions yeah to the point that
eventually
we broke up
and it was in large part by how guilty i
felt about the way that the relationship
had progressed uh physically and now
of course in the next episode we'll talk
like
all about the purity culture and that we
were in and and the emphasis that the
the applications that we made
but for now i'll say i remember this was
the point where we did start talking
about this
like
when we would go to the makeout parties
and even with the lock-in
you
you told me
what you did
and
i don't quite remember
if it had gotten to the point that it
got to later which we will discuss which
is like formalized accountability where
you were like confessing to me
and asking for
some help to to not do that again that
eventually happened but at first there
might have been a little i think that
might have been part of your motivation
i don't know if you recall when we first
started talking about it that it was
like confessional confessional but it
was also
hey i just i i did this and i'm like
it's great you know it's crazy and i
remember my application was
i'm behind
sure you know
i'm i thought they were i thought at the
makeout parties you were just making out
like you're doing stuff with your hands
dude yeah it's like
and
i was yeah just trying to figure out
before it all became about let's we have
to not do this we have to help each
other not do this
it there was that moment where it was
like ah
should i be doing more of this should i
oh gosh and then it was i mean
my girlfriend at the time we were we
were a pretty good match
in terms of not being too driven or
aspirational it was more just about
making out
aspirational if i flirted with a
boundary then she let me know
and great for her you know there was
communication that was like uh
i'm not this is not for me
kind of a thing but
we didn't have this
we weren't com we weren't communicating
it to the point or or getting
communicated to by anyone who said
this is how you're responsible
person in a relationship this is how you
communicate
um we were we were going on
we were just kind of like feeling our
way through it i guess literally at
times
uh but yeah i never
i was not
nearly as experienced as you were going
into high school well it's one of those
things where the timing of the the
engine getting started and then the rpms
getting really high
and then the opportunity of being in a
relationship with someone who felt the
same way
that was all sort of headed towards the
end zone or the you know the home plate
so to speak in a in a very intense way
but
it was the sort of assembly of the
christian worldview
that just stopped it
like stopped it really really
abruptly
you know what we're gonna get into next
episode is what it was like to navigate
you know that engine was still revving
it started revving even more for link a
little bit later
uh and it revved all right up until our
wedding day
and like what was it like getting from
that place where you began to
buy into this idea that sex is wrong sex
outside of marriage is wrong but to be
an adolescent kid with all the sex drive
and all this well you had more
opportunity than i did but i made some
opportunities for myself
um
what was it like to navigate that
through high school and then when it got
even weirder in college when we
went all in with purity culture
so that's what we're going to talk about
next time yeah and i'm i'm just struck
with how different
our experience was i mean it
it's the thing you know but then it's
very palpable like that how people
develop at different rates you know and
it's it's one of those areas where at
this particular time frame we were so
different
and yet ultimately
hey i did catch up and i we arrived at
basically the same place it's just a
matter of timing
and of course people arrive in all
different types of places too we're only
speaking about our experience which
ultimately got more in
lockstep as we'll talk about but
from a from that developmental
prepubescent puberty
stages
yeah we were in such different places
it's very fascinating and it does impact
it does make me start to think about
what we'll talk about episode after next
which is
how
how do we approach this as parents yeah
you know and i i i'm i'm very much
informed by
how
a lack of communication and just this
feeling of awkwardness and shame
these are things that i've tried to be
very pointed about heading off at the
pass
if one of my kids happens to be like i
was but even if
it they're totally different like like
how you came up in your experience
it's this the answer is still wrapped up
in communication i think you know we
both talked about how it would have been
helpful and i think that's something
that we'll get into week after next and
i think one of the really interesting
aspects of that conversation about
parenting um
is really rooted in
the sort of crazy
upheaval of our christian worldview that
christian worldview oh wow that took us
all the way
up into marriage and well into marriage
that was then
stripped away
um
and the underpinning of sort of the what
led to the purity culture was no longer
a part of our worldview
what does that do as you approach
parenting kids through
you know the desires stay the same but
the framework
the philosophical framework changes well
what does that mean
uh so we'll get into all that i'm
excited to have these conversations i
mean this one didn't make me nervous
i'm trying to figure out which ones do
we've had good conversations with
uh christy and jesse
the four of us talked about our approach
to this so i actually feel pretty good i
don't i don't know if i'm nervous about
any of it but i don't know what their
questions may be so again hashtag your
biscuits
uh go ahead and start
giving us your
what's on your what's on your mind if
you want to create a dummy account to do
it that's totally fine hashtag your
biscuits you got a rack i got a wreck
now let me just give my non-wreck
what i thought would be perfect to tie
in with this
is a book that has been many years since
i read i was going to recommend sex at
dawn which was a fascinating look at
sort of
the evolutionary
origins of monogamy
that was just kind of it was just a
really
crazy read that i was just intrigued by
but then as i was getting ready to look
it up for a wreck i realized that oh
this is a very popular book but the
scientific community has poked a bunch
of holes in this so you just made an
anti-wrap so if you want to read
something that's probably not true
according to many scientists but it's
really fun read sex at dawn but my real
wreck
is completely out of left field because
i was running low on ideas and i thought
i was gonna wreck that i'm gonna
recommend the eye drops that i use not a
sponsor
but
i have been accused of uh looking old
tired and
high many times in the history of the
internet
and uh i got so tired of those
accusations that i started to use
or high i started to use eye drops in
order to look alive and bright and
because i now have naturally sort of dry
irritated eyes and i have allergies so
my eyes always look a little bit red if
i don't take some sort of precautions
and
for years i just used to like you know
when we would shoot i would use like
visine but i started feeling i'm not i
shouldn't be using
these like visine type things because
there's this thing called the rebound
effect that if you can overuse them and
then your eyes actually become dependent
on
the the way that the blood vessels are
constricted so you use powdered sperm
yeah right in the eye there's a new
product it's not new but it's a couple
years old i've been using it called
lumify
which operates on a different receptor
has the same impact on your eye actually
in my case makes my eyes even wider than
any of those other products does
and it does it acts on receptors that do
not have a rebounding effect so you're
not going to become dependent on that
sounds like an ad so
it does sound like an ad but i'm just
giving you the facts about this product
that they may end up finding out that it
causes some other thing but so far it's
it's safe
and uh that's why i can say that kind of
thing when i'm not being paid to say it
uh yeah that's right lumify uh it's a
little bit more expensive than normal
eye drops at least last time i checked
it was uh try that if you've got really
bad eye problems and you don't want to
look high or old or tired on camera all
right see if you can hang on until next
week we will totally
blow your load oh gosh
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best